I’m Geoff McFetridge and this Beastie Boys Story Illustrated.
I started collaborating with the Beastie Boys around 1996 when I became the art director for Grand Royale Magazine.
As a fan of the Beastie Boys and working with them on and off for 25 years
I think it gives me a broad perspective of this band I have so much respect for.
In making these posters I was really interested in focusing on the Beastie Boys’ creativity in their work.
And I feel like using the iPad was a great tool to just spontaneously create in a very quick way.
The sketches I did on the iPad to begin the project was like well,
can I do one drawing that captures anything to do with the spirit of the Beastie Boys.
I wanted to have them moshing in a circle.
The instruments are gone, they’ve picked up the mics
so this is using the physicality of the guys and turning it into some sort of hieroglyphic language explaining the energy at the time
but then the thing I added at the end was this Mobius mic cord.
It’s a reference to this style the way they recorded the music all rapping the same line
and bouncing back and forth but also the Beastie Boys as one entity.
This is the check your head era. The shock of the Beastie Boys not just with microphones but with instruments.
This poster was them at their most abstract but sort of casting this shadow that they were this outsized influence on the world,
making this music that was so visceral and maybe more familiar, it felt like it came out of my friend’s parents’ basement.
They just look like skater guys, the wonky anonymity of them but they carried a lot of weight.
They’re attached which is sort of a theme in all the posters—they’re one unit melted together.
The “Sabotage” video was seismic. When this video came out it was a powerful piece of culture that came out of the Beastie Boys, but it was also Spike.
These two groups of people at their best, they made themselves icons, they sort of disappeared into these caricatures
and it was primarily car, this Caprice drawn here from memory that basically becomes a cop car.
This is the one poster that got a ton of movement which I think is funny because it’s an era of costumes and pretending and play.
And I think that aspect of being a band of both serious and full of attitude,
but at the same time it’s the longest game of dress up ever played in front of millions of people.
I sort of made it speaking about the Beastie Boys act as one unit.
This robot costume, each one of them have a part of it, the mastermind, the tape loop maker, and Mike D with one big foot and this giant arm.
None of it’s really functioning.
You see, as I evolved this poster it went from to them standing there—what made it better
was if I gave them more attitude if they started thrusting their arms in the air they were sort of like, “Yes don’t **** with us.”
But in the meantime, they’re in these ridiculous cardboard robot costumes, but they still have this BBoy, “we’re the best, don’t step to us” vibe.
They made something culturally that’s more real than the real them.
Culture goes on, it lives in a way more than actual humans.
There’s something really sort of important that I want to capture in this last poster,
that’s why I wrote the title for this before I wrote this drawing which was A Spiritual Quest on the Front Line of Popular Culture.
Mike D is like the struggle, he’s like coiled energy about to go.  Adam Horovitz is always in the air to out-rap, out-BBoy everybody on the block.
And then Yauch is like on the wheel of life, like he’s much closer to the center, he’s moved into the middle and he’s just, his energy is just a spiritual energy.
What’s sort of funny about this, but then is also poignant because he’s also the one that we’ve lost.
And so the magic of it is also wrapped in a sort of sadness.
There was so much of their artistic development that was done at the zenith of their fame.
Each one of these images is sort of capturing the guys at like a physical iconic truth about themselves.
I draw so much, the amount of time a drawing takes makes a real difference how much work I can get done.
Working on the iPad I can very quickly start to sketch and come up with ideas to a finished product.
I think the Beastie Boys Story is so relevant now.
They were making stuff for each other.
You make culture that is most relevant to the world right around you, which most often is your friends.
Make work for your friends.  For me that’s the best of culture, that’s the stuff I love.